[Music]
in body is a canvas news if [ __ ] is
submitted by Julius all times now okay
submitted by past the butter a woman
covers 90% of her body a body in tattoos
to be like her dad Wow
that's try to be a daddy's girl that's
hot as [ __ ] they should even touch you
like saying daddy's girls no does this
wait she wants her daddy's love no so
she's like trying to like pay homage to
her pups by inking all of her body so he
had he liked ads he had tens yes so she
says that her dad had two sleeves
growing up and so because of that she
knew that she always wanted all of it to
have I know right do you have tattoos so
this girl her name is Nadine she's 23
years old
it's young so how many years is that
from eighteen to twenty three and five
in five years she's covered 90% of her
body really expensive cheese
not the face it is expensive 90% Ryan
the face is so in right now the face is
probably first my least favorite thing
in tattoos is the face thing is now like
they go like face neck went outside like
wear whatever they could show first is
what they go and luckily I'm a fan she's
a self-proclaimed classic daddy's girl
and so she was saying that she was all
she was constantly looking at Pinterest
forums looking at new tattoo styles that
were coming out and body modifications
so she was deciding how she wanted to
look once she turned 18 cool
soon as she turned 18 she went ahead and
got her first tattoo oh and she actually
booked her first tattoo with her dad oh
so her dad said like because she said I
discussed my first tattoo with my dad
and he supported my decision saying as
long as you're sure you want to do it
and that's fine so then that's when they
went together but she kind of
she went like that fulsome yeah nine so
I said 90% of your body she also has a
variety of piercing scarification oh
that's just hardcore what is that the
kitchen nuts oh the [ __ ] tape so I've
heard of it
I've heard of branding and scarification
so then scarification they take like a
scalpel and they like cut sections of
your skin off so that when it rehe 'ls
over it comes back as scars so you can
get them as like designs and stuff like
that so people like will cut up their
head and [ __ ] like that their face their
arms and all that sort of stuff because
it comes back as like a it's like a
design if you do it right and then
branding they take like steam hot iron
and they like will brand you and like
design that's a popular in the NFL
really well players know that Brandi
yeah did they bring their arms and [ __ ]
yeah yeah shit's hardcore
that's like next level if they do this
thing where it like that fraternities
scar tissue like from I think from
cauterize there at all probably out
there getting it burned it's something
similar yeah yeah damn yeah and she also
got hey oh [ __ ] those are wild
I can't watch those actually flew to
Germany to do her tongue because in the
UK they have laws that prevent piercing
parlors from carrying out that procedure
like a surgical procedure look and it
can move it like independently it's not
a bacterial issue if you slice it up in
my pan I don't know yeah I'm such a
bloomer [ __ ] it
yeah anyway maybe looks good seen the
[ __ ] black [ __ ] good that's
[ __ ] I don't know if you're being I'm
serious that same thing no he just has
two sleeves oh my god he only has two
sleeves this chick is looks like venom
yeah so what exactly does she plan you
don't hit me cuz like to plan it's like
I'm gonna get a tiger and I'm gonna get
at this and that but it's like all black
pink initially what happened is that she
got some tattoos here and there and then
she kind of got too addicted and she
started doing blackout tattoos yeah this
injection of 10 I wonder how many hours
that is she's beautiful though
pretty but you don't seems not like
scarification on her forehead some damn
she is oh my lord
however hurts I think that's [ __ ]
easy no to give that it's not it's not
easy at all to get it and to give it
it's not easy
who the [ __ ] thinks that because people
think is just blacking it out oh so
people thing like designs are a harder
yeah intricate oh yeah no that would be
painful I mean cuz now just to get the
full shade and like like you do the same
you get that much ink into the skin and
hold it well black is [ __ ] painful
like this oh wait this I can't
it's painful you know how when we dye
our hair in the shower and it all comes
out yeah does it look like that after
tattooing your old pot a little bit
your first meteor shower the last a lot
of the color comes out yeah plasma yeah
but it stays you shower over like aren't
you not supposed to wet it clean you
clean it like it's actual wound yeah so
you're not like scrubbing it but it's
like if you were to cut yourself or if
you're to get like a bernie still clean
it with soap and even with the water and
stuff like you literally run over your
arm like the way that I did it with you
just let it run over my arm to like kind
of like clean it off no like with cold
water with hot wha well like it not like
haha but like warm water because I have
Santa dirt ice well I also have Santa
drum on it too so if you get like a
Santa derm layer it's like a it's like a
big it's like a sticky saran wrap that
they put over it's a big bandage
yeah so you can leave it on and then you
can shower with it and then it'll stay
sealed and everything so it doesn't like
get all gross but yeah but after you
take it off yeah you got to like clean
it like I did yeah well I don't think
that stuff was invented back then they
just use like saran wrap it's only a
recent thing because the first couple
sessions I had it gave me saran wrap
does a [ __ ] do that thing [ __ ] stuck
because it like just slid all over the
place and like fell off you walk into
the room it sound like you're wearing a
diaper yeah dude I felt like a baby okay
so painful looking tan here's some more
photos never close hold on that probably
Wow oh is that the scarification oh it's
kind of raised this is part of the 10%
that is uncovered yo she actually wants
to fill in more that style looks like I
saw this vice documentary on like this
new movement of tattoos that's going
through Europe's it's like called the
pain black movement or something like
that where they're just they don't even
care about designs they're just trying
to go with like whatever is the most
painful so it's like the experience of
just a [ __ ] ton of painting time yeah
and it looks like that Wow
why would you wanna cut that thing that
actually looks like a cool design I want
you to start filming it it just feels
like I guess for her like there's too
much light skin skin what if it's like
putting on foundation it's holy crap
that looks like something Taikan did
this even wears we good
that's actually a good point like after
a certain point how much makeup do you
need it it's all I colored in anyway it
does look like a kid took a pan in just
yes I could just went a ham on her face
sketches and then maybe it maybe take
his dad help with the neck yeah do we
know how much money she spent over the
fire yeah she spent almost ten thousand
US dollars it all right
it was nine thousand four hundred us I
feel like that's very inexpensive yeah
for the amount of coverage twenty yeah
that sounds more like it I was like wow
that's actually kind of lovely this is
like ten like if you get your full back
19400 yeah that's that's I respected the
deal initially but you know just like oh
I might be in the Lord now yeah over the
last five years spending twenty I love
that [ __ ] though I like when people see
their body as like a canvas and like
they change it or modify it whether
that's with you know the scarification
or the piercings or even just clothing I
think that all that shit's not gonna
beautifly surgery all that [ __ ] I'm cool
with all that are you get worried yeah
even that too I think it's I feel like
I'll get to your question I feel like
yeah that it's [ __ ] lame and then I
like some people just want to look a
certain way and that's like their art
and I'm like [ __ ] yeah do that [ __ ] this
is the and am I gonna get more yes I
don't know when the guy that I want to
get my [ __ ] from my tattoo from he's in
Spain
get on the wait list he lives in Spain
yeah is the other wait list is one of
those guys oh yeah did you get on the
with us ready
no get on the waitlist what you wanted I
do know what I want a tiger for say I
want it right here hardcore parkour you
love it huh huh you love it it's cool
yeah I think it's I think it's dope I
wouldn't do it to myself you'd like to
love yeah yeah I think it's cool yeah
it's she's ballsy she's she's I would
love to see what establishment employee
would be employing her when when you
guys come back so you mentioned
something like that when you guys get
tattoos do you guys ever take like pain
killers no I would take it if they made
it I think they leave more right because
it the blood thinner I've taken advil I
went in for my sessions and it's it's
helped a lot actually yeah it took yeah
I only want I started though because
like it's it helps for the first part so
you're not as tired when he gets to this
like eight hour or whatever but I know
that I've had other friends that have
taken on oxy or something like that and
he took that before he started and then
his tattoo artist was like after going
for so long he's like we're gonna stop
because you're bleeding too much he's
like oh I didn't feel any of that
he's going oh part of the whole
experience you feel the pain yeah just a
quick plug there yeah don't do oxy
though I feel all like queasy yeah like
my skin feels like it's crawling right
now from the cuts are from the tattoos
for both everything this entire story is
making a big problem feels like it's
nickname I would get knees name or
teardrop [ __ ] oh you guys it hidden I
would do our wedding day
oh all right now we'd do a Tonka truck
and I won't tell you what did you get
out like a tonka truck why I didn't want
to know why why won't I I won't tell you
I will not tell you please don't even
tell us right he told me a secret yeah
both the off-camera anyway so you were
talking about her not being employed
right so she says this they say things
like you brew engines
if you can't be employees you'll regret
this in 40 years a bad Scottish accent
honey sure but at the end of the day I'm
fully employed I'm paid for every single
tattoo by Harley Davidsons out of my own
wages
no one's ever paid for them I've got my
own flat and honestly I live a very
normal life I think when people's
perspective is their canvas and it's art
I think it's harder for people to regret
it when people view that like their body
as a canvas and tattoo is just this
artwork and paint that they're
collecting then I feel like people tend
to regret that less just because that
perception is just different so yeah
why'd you get like what's with the cuz
you know you always ask yeah how would
you at that yeah and say hey why'd you
get like oh you're [ __ ] all over oh
she's got the dad story no I don't but
holy [ __ ] like are shaking she'd be like
[ __ ] private I don't want to share it so
they're saying there was this one a
global staffing firm that pulled more
than two thousand eight hundred senior
managers in the United States and
discover that about a third of them said
that tattoos and non traditional
piercings are now considered
sufficiently professional and there are
one in three people in New York that you
see in the workplace now before it's
like you've always got to be covered up
and all that but now you see like a lot
of medical professionals lot of people
with like exposed tattoos it's getting
normalized
yeah even listen if I was at a [ __ ]
hospital and this chick walked in I
would be like yo [ __ ] venom she looks
like me but she's so hot
she's very attractive about cream I'm
like whoa she looks like a parasite has
covered her body and she's not gonna be
a little [ __ ] she's not gonna be all
squirmy
I know I know I'm not yeah no good for
her man she likes it that's great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]